موجه حر شديد في اوروبا تتخطى الحراره
اربعين درجه مئويه في بعض المدن اسبانيا
وفرنسا واليونان وكرواتيا وايطاليا
وتتصاعد المخاوف من اندلاع حرائق ناجمه عن
موجه الحر هذه والتي يتوقع ان تزداد سوءا
رغم ذلك تنشغل القاره بالترحيب بتدفق
السياح اليها وتبذل جهودا في محاولات
حمايتهم السلطات الاسبانيه اعلنت اجلاء ما
لا يقل عن الفي شخص بعد اندلاع حرائق
الغابات وخروجها عن السيطره في جزيره
لابالما وفي اليونان حضرت السلطات الوصول
الى الغابات والمحميات الطبيعيه بسبب
تزايد مخاطر اندلاع حرائق الغابات حتى
موقع البارسينون الشهير الذي يزوره
الملايين اجبر للمره الاولى على الاغلاق
لبضع ساعات يوم الجمعه ومع
توقع طقس حارق حتى الاسبوع المقبل تظل
اليونان في حاله تاهب قصوى
ان الحراره هي احد اكثر التغيرات الجويه
فتكا